[Musique]
80 % des gens vont au travail avec la
boule au ventre
quand je suis entré dans cet amphi il y
à 19 ans j'étais assis à votre place et
je ne savais pas qu'un homme allait
changer ma vie avec ces mots
c'était directeur de l'école
il était là sur scène pour accueillir
tous les étudiants de notre promo
il nous a parlé de management
technologique
nos responsabilités des tic
mais il a surtout eu ces mots que je
n'oublierai jamais
il nous a dit
80% les gens vont au travail avec la
boule au ventre vos études sont courtes
elle dure trois ou quatre ans
alors profitez-en pour trouver ce que
vous voulez faire mais surtout pour
trouver ce que vous ne voulez pas faire
pour moi ces mots ont été une révolution
c'était la confirmation que dans la vie
j'allais pouvoir faire ce que je voulais
et qu'en plus on allait me payer pour ça
il y avait juste un problème problème
majeur entre eux ces mots inspirant
cette vision est la réalité
j'avais 19 ans
et je ne savais pas du tout ce que je
voulais faire
du marketing de la finance des rh
j'étais perdu
à l'époque j'étais boursiers donc pour
financer mes études j'étais serveurs
dans les bars de la ville et tous les
soirs j'avais parmi mes clients les mecs
les plus cools et les plus populaires de
l'école des étudiants du master
entrepreneurs et ceux du master achats
dans la vie on a tous besoin de modèles
et eux
il m'inspirait il avait l'air d'aimer ce
qu'il faisait
il allait bien gagner leur vie et
surtout il était dehors tous les soirs
je me suis dit eux c'est sûr ils vont
faire partie des 20 % de gens heureux de
se lever pour aller travailler
alors j'ai décidé de les imiter et j'ai
postulé pour le masters entrepreneurs
c'était la filière la plus sélective il
y avait des entretiens mais je me suis
dit c'est bon ça va bien se passer je
vais y arriver
seulement tout ne s'est pas passé comme
prévu probablement parce que je suis
arrivé avec vingt minutes de retard un
bon entretien de motivation
là le directeur du master entrepreneurs
il a levé les yeux vers moi et il a eu
ces mots il m'a dit tu sais
être entrepreneur c'est avant tout être
fiable et la fiabilité ça commence par
la conque tu alité si un jour tu deviens
entrepreneurs des salariés et leurs
familles compteront sur toi alors
revient dans un an quand aura pris un
peu de plomb dans la tête moi tout ce
que j'ai entendu
c'était tu n'es pas assez bien
alors je me suis rabattu sur le master h
à un peu par dépit j'ai quand même
travaillé pour des grands groupes
industriels comme general electric
schneider electric et valeo mais s'était
pas pour moi je n'étais pas à ma place
dès mon premier stage dans les achats
j'ai vite compris que mon logiciel
c'était ward et pas excellent
mes collègues mes patrons ont vite
compris aussi tout simplement parce que
je travaillais pas j'étais toute la
journée sur internet à lire l'équipe a
cherché de nouveaux blogs et a joué à
questions pour un champion
parfois j'ai les mêmes m'enfermer aux
toilettes pour lire des livres parce que
depuis que je suis tout petit la lecture
ça a toujours été l'activité inspirante
et apaisante vers laquelle je me tourne
quand j'ai besoin de me retrouver seule
dans mon
mais là il fallait bien que je me rende
à l'évidence si je continuais comme ça
j'allais tout droit vers les 80 % de
français qui vont au travail à reculons
ma vie est en train de devenir un
cauchemar métro boulot dodo
j'étais en train de mourir d'ennui au
bureau alors que je rêvais de vivre des
aventures au dehors comme les modèles
tintin superman
et carrie bradshaw aussi la chroniqueuse
new yorkaise de sex and the city leur
point commun ils écrivent et ils vivent
tous des aventures folles
alors un jour j'ai décidé de m'évader de
mon quotidien et de m'échapper avec les
mots j'ai écrit un premier texte que
j'ai décidé de soumettre à mon blog
préféré et les éditeurs ont accepté de
le publier c'est grâce à eux que j'ai
découvert le pouvoir des mots et
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de le partager
avec vous avec tout le monde pour que
vous puissiez changé votre vie
celle des autres mais pourquoi pas
changer le monde
mais avant changer le monde on va
commencer par vous
parce que je sais que tout n'est pas si
simple
j'ai lu un article récemment dans le
journal des sciences comportementales
il paraît que 70% des gens souffrent à
un moment de leur vie du syndrome de
l'imposteur ça veut dire que si j'en
prends dix parmi vous dans la salle 6
vont avouer ne pas se sentir au niveau
et je serai le 7e
et c'est pas si grave c'est pas si grave
mais je sais que vous avez tous dit des
mots comme je suis pas au niveau je suis
pas assez bien je ne suis pas assez ceci
je suis trop cela c'est pas un problème
parce que même les grands patrons même
les grands champions ils sont touchés
par ce syndrome de l'imposteur mais chez
eux ça se traduit souvent par du
perfectionnisme et généralement on
hérite de cette mauvaise estime de nous
à cause d'un parent trop exigeant pour
qui rien n'est jamais assez bien
le problème c'est que ça peut avoir des
conséquences durables
vous connaissez will smith
oscar du meilleur acteur 2022
premier acteur à être payé 100 millions
de dollars devant tom cruise tom hanks
tom hardy leonardo dicaprio et tous les
autres
will smith quand son film sort en
décembre 2007 iam legends il fait un
démarrage canon à 77 millions de dollars
record à l'époque pour un film sorti en
décembre
et prend son téléphone il appelle son
meilleur ami et lui dit qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui nous a manqué
pour ouvrir à 80 millions
77 millions
ce n'était pas assez
pourquoi ce perfectionnisme pourquoi
cette insatisfaction permanente
pourquoi ce manque de confiance en lui
la réponse est à chercher 40 ans en
arrière dans les mots que le père a
transmis office son père lui répéter en
permanence
99% c'est la même chose que 0%
la version de mon père était moins
mathématiques plus littéraire il me
répétait un travail ça se fait de a à z
à chaque fois que je rendais un devoir
un parfait quand j'étais petit je
faisais pas mes devoirs comme les autres
camarades j'ai été obligé de les faire
deux fois une première fois au brouillon
mon père corrigé validé puis je pouvais
les faire au propre et seulement après
j'avais le droit de rejoindre mes
copains au foot
ce besoin de perfection cette exigence
constante mon conditionné et m'ont
ralenti parfois forcément quand tu fais
tout deux fois quand tu doutes de toi ça
prend plus de temps
on est en lisant de nouveaux mots dans
un livre
fait est mieux que parfait
j'ai pu me libérer de ce script qui
m'empêchait d'avoir confiance en moi
et vous
quels sont les mots qui vont vous
permettre
de prendre confiance en vous
comme je suis coach je suis pas venu les
mains vides j'ai trois petits exercices
pour vous
il implique tous un carnet et un stylo
le premier exercice je vais vous
demander pour prendre confiance en vous
grâce au pouvoir des mots de noter vos
objectifs en notant des objectifs vous
le savez écrire vous engage la paroles
s'envolent mais les écrits restent
quand vous aurez vos objectifs devant
les yeux ça vous forcera rester
concentré dessus et le plaisir de rayer
votre to do list à chaque ligne qui s'en
va c'est un vrai sentiment de confiance
un vrai motif de fierté
en parlant de fierté ça va être votre
deuxième exercice je l'appelle la liste
de fierté vous allez prendre votre
carnet et écrire toutes vos fierté
toutes vos réussites tout ce que vous
avez vraiment réussi dans la vie et qui
vous motive je donne un exemple quand
j'étais plus petit ça pouvait être j'ai
eu mon brevet j'ai eu mon bac j'ai
réussi mes concours et j'ai intégré
l'école de mes rêves de manière moins
académique ça peut être je suis
asthmatique mais j'ai couru le 10 km en
45 minutes j'ai gagné à questions pour
un champion et j'ai écrit trois livres
notez vos réussites dans votre carnet
est retourné à chaque fois que vous
aurez besoin de vous remonter le moral
le troisième exercice enfin il est très
connu et vraiment je les adore parce
qu'il est très très simple
ce troisième exercice
c'est un exercice de gratitude qui
s'appelle les 3 kifs par jour en fin de
journée vous prenez votre carnet et vous
repensé aux trois choses aux trois
moments aux trois rencontres qui vous
ont marqué et comme ça vous allez rester
concentré sur les choses positives et ça
vous remontera le moral c'est très
important pour moi le choix des mots
positifs au quotidien ne dit plus on va
prendre un petit café dit je vais
prendre un café ne dites plus ça va pas
trop mal dites que vous allez bien ne
dites plus que vous voudriez écrire un
livre mais écrivait le plan en plus
maintenant vous avez un joli carnet tout
neuf
notez vos objectifs soyez positif et
passer à l'action
et vous verrez qu'à partir du moment où
vous vous sentirez mieux vous pourrez
passer à la phase 2 et créer du lien
avec les mots
faut que je vous confie un secret
séduire et vendre c'est la même chose
c'est la deuxième étape dans notre
progression
avec les mots
au début on commence tout seul puis on
va aller vers les autres parce que
l'homme est un animal social
les anglais disent no man is and islands
personne ne peut rester seul et les mots
vont vous permettre de bâtir des ponts
vous permettre de nouer des relations
amicales amoureuses
commercial
je suis copywriter mon métier c'est de
vendre avec les mots j'écris des livres
j'écris des mails j'écris de la
publicité pour que les produits de mes
clients séduisent le client final
est ce que j'ai appris avec les années
c'est que les plus grands séducteurs
et les meilleurs vendeurs utilisent tous
les mêmes mots
la même structure de mots pour être
précis
cette structure en quatre étapes elle
s'appelle la méthode aïda
le à 2 attirance le i2 intérêts le d de
désir et le à de l'action
pour séduire il faut commencer pas
attirer l'attention de l'autre
avec un look original avec du parfum qui
sent bon avec un rire qui s'entend
depuis l'autre bout de la salle
dans la pub on utilise un gros titres
une phrase choc un visuel qui interpelle
ensuite vous devrez intéressé votre
cible lui parler d'elle
lui faire comprendre que vous la
comprenez vous allez lui parler de ses
problèmes
puis il sera temps de susciter le désir
comment faire en lui promettant une
solution en lui peignant un futur
radieux en lui rappelant qu'elle est
unique
et enfin votre cible ne pourra pas
profiter de tout ça de toute cette
sublime offre si elle ne passe pas à
l'action alors voulu expliquer qu' il
faudrait qu'à monte boire un dernier
verre à la maison ou dans la pub qu'elle
cliquer sur s'abonner en savoir plus ou
ajouter au panier
il existe des mots puissants qui vous
permettront de séduire de vendre
d'influencé de persuader le monde entier
et si vous maîtrisez ces mots magiques
vous pourrez vendre aux personnes qui
souffrent la solution à leurs problèmes
la meilleure version de même vous
pourrez aussi trouver l'amour et même
devenir riche et une fois que vous serez
arriver à cette étape là vous pourrez
commencer à utiliser le pouvoir des mots
de manière moins égoïste et plus
altruiste vous pourrez vraiment penser à
aider les autres et à changer le monde
parce que notre monde est violent et qu
à notre échelle nous pouvons tous
contribuer à améliorer les choses
alors certes nous ne serons pas tous
rosa parks
qui a dit non et s'est dressé contre la
ségrégation
ne seront pas tous des martin luther
king avec des discours célèbre émotive
en inspirant que magna veut dream ne
seront peut-être pas non plus winston
churchill le meilleur orateur du siècle
dernier
morin de ces essais sur la rhétorique
winston churchill écrivait que se
serait-il passé si au lieu de dire nous
nous battrons sur les plages j'avais dit
les hostilités seront engagées avec
notre adversaire sur le périmètre côtier
les mots ont leur importance et vous
pouvez dès aujourd'hui
utiliser les mots pour changer votre
environnement votre entourage vous
pouvez commencer par opter pour la
posture de confident le confident c'est
celui qui dit 0 mots
parfois les mots les plus forts sont
ceux que vous ne prononcerait pas
vous écouterez sans juger sans rien dire
sans proposer de solutions quand un
proche aura besoin de parler à la suite
d'une rupture d'un licenciement d'un
échec
la deuxième posture c'est celle de coach
celui qui maîtrise les mots pour faire
passer les autres à l'action
nicolas de tavernost le patron de m6
déclaré ceci
le leadership ça avoir confiance en soi
et donner confiance autour de soi à
votre niveau vous pouvez envoyer des
textos motivant à votre voisin qui se
prépare pour le marathon vous vous
pouvez glisser la technique de la liste
de fierté
vous pouvez aussi utiliser le pouvoir
des mots pour réécrire le cv ou la
lettre de motivation de vos proches de
vos collègues qui en ont besoin
vous pouvez aussi à la maison dans un
cadre plus privé
soutenir votre partenaire ou votre
enfant qui traverse une phase de moins
bien en écrivant des mots mignon et en
collant des post-it partout dans la
maison
je crois en toi tu peux y arriver je
t'aime tu es la plus forte
les mots peuvent avoir cet impact est
véritablement changer des vies et la
troisième
solution que vous pouvez mettre en place
dès demain c'est d'apprendre de nouveaux
mots vous avez le pouvoir de faire
baisser les conflits en apprenant de
nouveaux mots il est prouvé qu'on
devient plus facilement violent
quand on manque de mots
je vous incite donc apprendre à partir
d'aujourd'hui un nouveau mot par jour
c'est le concept pour lequel milite
clairement chalon entrepôts compteur il
milite pour le mot du jour à l'école
pour élargir le vocabulaire des enfants
afin de faire baisser le niveau de
violence scolaire et j'ose espérer que
si la violence baisse à l'école il y en
aura moins dans la rue - la maison et
moi entre les nations
on me fait signe que notre moment
ensemble est bientôt terminée alors
j'aimerais conclure
avec ce mot qui a changé ma vie qui
changera peut-être la vôtre et qui va
changer le monde merci quand je suis
entré
dans cet amphi il y a dix huit minutes
j'aurais préféré être à votre place
parce que j'étais pétrifiée mais j'avais
écrit je m'étais donné une mission vous
prouver que si vous changez vos mots
vous pouvez changer le monde
et même si ce n'était pas parfait au
moins c'est fait merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]